the last three videos threw you into all
the basic features of romance firm
endings the helping verbs you'll meet
this time also have endings that reflect
those same basic features so you'll need
to be familiar with them Aveda can be
present indicative abbess preterite
evasive or present subjunctive obvious
to throw just a few forms away with all
of those endings in mind take a look at
two helping verbs a beta and s setting
why can they act as helping verbs while
they sometimes sit next to a meeting
heavy verb like cantata but do most of
the grammatical work
the main content verb cantate in this
example is in sum in variable or less
variable form these forms are typically
non personal they carry no person number
information in their ending
you've met one of these forms already
the infinitive like Katahdin
but verbs also have a past participle
like can't Otto
these can be adjectives as in very
broken tattle
but they're also very handy in phrases
with a beret
özkan tato vamoose can tato
gerunds and present participles also
exists cantando
cantante
rewind to that example I showed you with
a bear I can tattoo perfect what's going
on here it's the same thing that happens
in English have some the main
grammatical verb have isn't the same as
the main content verb some in French
Italian and other central Romance
languages the verb aesthetic comes into
play with verbs of motion and other
verbs that don't take direct objects as
seta has unexpected forms so for vanilla
to come we find s22 in these languages a
Venuto 11 e xi yi
with s-sarah these participles describe
the person performing the action so they
have to match the number and gender of
the subject below fill us Veneto versus
allah philia east Vinita not so with a
beret aloo filio at condado allah philia
at cantata
liberian and romanian languages use a
beta with all verbs Benny they included
ave neva a vineeth Romanian Italian
romantic French and Sardinian used this
perfect tense for their regular past
tense instead of the preterite gondii
which we find for example in formal
written Italian or French
compare this to Spanish or Portuguese
which continue the use of gondii
colloquially
it is some it is done this same way of
forming the passive is found in romance
with ascetic plus a past participle s
can't Otto scream at him and to write
script who is the past participle
written what do you think a script o
means that's a perfect construction
what about ESTs creep do that's a
passive
there's another very popular romance
passive that goes like this
say scream it literally it writes itself
which we'll learn about later
the help of romance helping verbs
doesn't stop there
modal verbs like the auxiliaries can
want to need to or ought to our mood
verbs that introduce an infinitive
bhasu Cantara
Debu can't re
another use of auxiliaries Western
Romance languages have the equivalent of
go to before an infinitive for near
future events much like English does
Lacan tada
like a death eventual T and one more use
of helping verbs Western Romance
languages not including French can use
study as a helping verb with a gerund to
point out something being done right now
stat cantando
stammers confounded Sardinian uses
s-sarah in the same way so cantonment
seems container
as Senate and Abeyta get a lot of
mileage in the modern languages beyond
their uses auxiliaries Aveda is heard in
many everyday phrases like as family and
a Trat unit
as soon as the copula or linking verb
Alaka sized magna or illa fiji Sun
Dominus if you've been following along
so far I congratulate you
you've made it through romance verbs and
now you're prepared for problems